whatever we have around retirement is
designed for the old days where
retirement has lasted 28 years on
average let's go less like 30 wow and so
what i'm really helping people do is
reimagine this block of time
letting go of some of the preconceived
notions of what retirement it's it's not
necessarily since it's not a time of
decline it's a time of expiration
opportunity if you've got that
inclination to what put the limit
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of make-a-wish israel and tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret core adventures
j ventures riverside fm
fusion vc
birthright excel j impact
leap google for startups and hippo and
in media partnership with ctec
welcome to 20 minute leaders this
episode is about retirement well not
really but yes really this is about
sort of what happens when people finish
their full-time job and still have a lot
of energy room and excitement to explore
many more things
please meet joe casey managing partner
of retirement wisdom and the author of
when the retirement game which is
launching on august 9th now joe is is a
coach he's an executive coach previously
he was senior vice president
at merrill lynch and so this is a really
fascinating conversation about his
outlook on these opportunities and how
to be intentional about what people do
in their retirement
joey is an executive coach who also
helps people create meaningful lives
after their primary careers he works
with people who aren't done yet to
figure out what's next
it is not a theoretical for joe he's
done it himself becoming a coach 13
years ago after a 26-year career at
merrill lynch where he was senior vice
president and head of hr for global
markets and investment banking
business insider named joe is one of 23
innovative coaches who are making a
difference
joe your your journey is so awesome from
senior vice president at merrill lynch
um
to now managing partner with retirement
wisdom thinking about this next phase in
a very strategic and coherent way
coaching people through this transition
something that's a little far from you
know my world and i'm so excited to jump
into your world and figure out you know
what
how people are managing through these
different transitions and and the
different things that you've been
observing about them and yourself
throughout this process so again thank
you very very much for being here
great to be here and i'll just point out
that many of my clients some are in
their mid 40s
it's like when you drive in your car you
see the mirror and such objects may be
closer than they appear
[Music]
with retirement or this next chapter
it's always a little closer than you may
think
interesting what do you mean by that
i think that's a lot of things that you
can do during your career will help set
you up for your next chapter perhaps a
second act or life after you
his wife put a graduate from the world
of full-time work into this next
endeavor and a lot of it comes from
the network the connections that you
built the things you're involved in
outside of your main responsibilities
and cultivating your imagination in
terms of what could be once you have the
resources and time to be able to do
anything you want
incredible so joe tell me a little bit
about your own career and
what what made you want to
deal with retirement as a you know sort
of from a coaching perspective yeah
how did that happen so i'm a former hr
person i worked 26 years at one company
in merrill lynch but had
a lot of diverse experience because i
worked in hr supporting different parts
of the company from the wealth
management division through technology
and then investment banking sales and
trading in anything outside of the us in
terms of merrill lynch international
and got to work with a lot of different
people and when i was promoted to a
senior in leadership role i had a coach
for a year because in retrospect they
must have been a hard case but it
changed how i really saw
myself as leader saw the ripple effect
it had on my team and the company's
divisions that i supported
and i got really curious about coach
what happened to make me a more
effective leader
and begin to study coaching talk to some
of the coaches that we had became
curious about which and once but really
did
better than the others
and i knew that after hr i wanted to do
something in the country field and want
to have a coaching career so when we
were acquired i thought what better time
i was 52 at the time
and went back to school
wow columbia to be trained as a coach
did a master's degree in coaching you
know uk
university at 50.
yeah 52. and 52. wow that's incredible
that's incredible
i thought i thought i'd do it a little
later but well i thought why not do it
now and it was a great experience
especially with the investment i made in
terms of studying it really getting a
solid grounding and as part of that i've
had the opportunity to interview 20 of
the top coaches people like marshall
goldsmith in person pre-covet obviously
uh in the us and uk and learn how they
developed their expertise to coach
because i figured i don't really have 25
years to learn this let me get a head
start awesome that was great
and i still do
executive coaching today it's my primary
focus i work with large companies
fortune 100 i also do a lot in
private equity backed companies like
coach ceos of those those firms as well
and
about seven years ago so so seven years
six years into my coaching research
coach career
one of my clients who was being groomed
to be the successor to the ceo he was 52
also said to me halfway through the
process
i've decided i don't want to be the ceo
can you help me figure out what to do
next because i want to retire early at
and i want to do something with impact
something philanthropic something
greater than myself
and i thought
i don't really know and i have a
conflict so i can't help you with that
but let me see what resources i can find
for you
by the way i just want to make sure joe
i just want to understand when he says
the word i want to retire at 55 but then
he it's accompanied by a lot of doing
right i mean i heard the word retirement
and then i heard a whole bunch of
aspirations and motivation for things to
do so i'm getting a little confused what
what is what is retirement then
sure so i think retirement for the
people i work with today
is
what are you going to do after
full-time work meaning
when you have some freedom you have some
flexibility and working becomes optional
how do you want to use investor time
people who want to play golf
just travel
hang around
chill get kicked back
they don't really need someone like me
sure those are those who have a fire in
their bellies so they're retiring quote
unquote but they're not done yet
find value working with someone like
myself to really map out what it is
because most have some vague ideas like
he did uh vague ideas about what they
can do it's a matter of thinking through
what are different ways in which you can
use your skill set and redeploy it
because many people i find in your
40s 50s and 60s
are looking for two things greater
meaning and purpose
and more flexibility
so they're not necessarily working
looking to jump into the mix full-time
thing
but something where works gonna be part
of their next
phase
but part of a broader portfolio of
things that have been
and that was that was the case with most
people i'm not looking at this
and what's also going on there is even
in your case
we're getting older every day i need to
break it to you and so learning about
the aging process really helps quite a
bit
i went back to school to get a third
masters in gerontology the study of life
course at usc because i wanted to make
sure i was well prepared for advising
coaching clients in this in this regard
and it turns out that there's some
really important things
number one
that their
sense of purpose meaning purpose
actually can help determine how long you
live
there was this great study at the
university of michigan back in 2019 that
found that
those who have a
clearer sense of purpose
live on average about seven years longer
wow how do you measure that though how
do you measure
sense of purpose
sure there's a study uh there's a
database called the
health and retirement study uh which
looks at it's been running many many
years and they look at
at people over the long longitudinal
basis and then
examine
those who who
unfortunately passed away and those who
didn't
evaluated based on some call to quality
of
questionnaires
another set of research was done by
becca levy and yale which looked at
how people view the aging progress do
they think about getting older is a
negative thing some of the stereotypes
that are there since the period decline
what do they think is a period of
opportunity mastery et cetera and those
who look at it more optimistically lived
on average
seven and a half years
wow so it's not it's the length of time
but the quality of those years that's
also involved
so what i try to do with my clients is
bring something really important into
retirement planning
imagination
you think about when you're thinking
about getting rid of retirement you've
got to get the money right
and that's a left-brained activity get a
reps advisor or if you do it yourself
you're going to really
deal with longevity how long you likely
live in the resources that you like and
these how you can manage that et cetera
et cetera but there's a smaller side of
it how you invest your time
and that's where it takes some
imagination
interesting and tell me a little bit
about you know the the work that you're
doing
one-on-one with these people what does
that imagination work
tangibly look like
sure so i'm trained in a process that
was developed by two stanford folks bill
burnett and dave evans bill bernard runs
the design school there graduate
division and
dave evans uh
teaches there he has taught a course
here for i think over 15 years now
called designing your life he wrote a
book in 2016
new york times bestseller and have had
two follow-ups to it focusing on the new
world of work
but basically what it does is it
takes the principles of design thinking
it applies it to landing your life and
career
and it works particularly well with
people at this stage of life it's really
the way i use those coaches three phases
phase one is taking a step back
and looking at your values and
priorities now because they might be
different
than they were earlier in the career in
life
and what are the things that really
energize you in to read energy to really
get a look at what are the critical
building blocks that phase two is idea
generation
using a technique they developed called
mind mapping which brings more
creativity into the process and then
secondly moving into three alternative
visions of your future because their
view is there's multiple alternative
visions of the future you
so we map out three
over five years
so when i went through the training with
them in person san francisco i did mine
and
when
i packed up my office and took speakers
did my office stay in prince new jersey
frustrated in the university here
where clovis did i looked at things that
i need to bring home for the next few
weeks pause for laughter
well it turns out that on the on that uh
odyssey plan that i found and said i'll
bring that home too
smack in the middle of it was a drawing
in my first play of a book
because i decided during that process to
write a book and i'm now publishing the
book on august 9th
incredible
exactly primarily from derivative from
that process so you get the idea
generation something like that like
something else for many other people
and then phase three is prototyping we
really take these ideas in reality test
them through conversations with other
people
and that's particularly valuable because
you start to find out from others who
have done what you're looking to do what
the realities are what they love how
they get into it their story not yours
and you really get a better better idea
i had one person one client who
found something valuable by deciding
what she was planning turned out not to
be what you wanted to do she was a
senior person at a financial firm in new
york
was retiring it had signed up and be
accepted for fellowship and saw your
university actually
and
when we went to prototype in i guess
who could talk to have been through the
program so actually no one
so she interviewed my people and
discovered it wasn't really what she
allowed to do huh
so she made a different decision built a
portfolio of prayer in life with
consulting going back to art school a
bunch of houses
and she called me about
nine months ago and said those best
decisions
wow sometimes
not the path is equally as important
without this
incredible tell me a little bit about
your own journey here you know how you
know you're you're so intentional you're
not just
you know reading these books and talking
about what you're right you're actively
going you're going back to get second
and third masters you're you're actively
engaging with this in in the most
intentional way well what what really
drove you to do this what really drove
you to be so intentional about this
so i've always been curious so that
leads to being a lifelong learner my
wife has a different version of how
she'll describe it says well i know he's
a lifelong learner but that's because he
has so much to learn
but i think it's it starts with the
curiosity of learning actually the first
chapter of my my book goes into one of
the biggest things that people confess
to me when they start with musical
especially men
is they're afraid of being bored you're
retired coming off a dynamic career
and when you think about it the story
departure once you're the antidote to
boredom is curious
if you're curious you'll never be bored
there's something else and so
on it's always been i've been driven by
two things
lifelong learning
and then helping others develop and grow
and that's what i do now in both this
i also as you do
talk to people weekly out of pockets and
so i talked to all kinds of different
people like you do and i learned
tremendous amounts from
their experiences their journeys and
what they're discovered interesting
did you
know
you know a few years ago when you
started working on specifically on the
retirement front did you realize the
impact that this may have that that this
is literally you know potentially life
life altering
mindsets just like the phone call that
you received nine months ago is
i i get that coaching is important and
people getting gain a lot of benefit
from it but but here it sounds like
tangibly your chain you're helping
somebody navigate
through a very just confusing time that
even if they have been very successful
in the past
now there it's a new challenge or it's
uncharted territory that
they've evidently that they've never
been to because they have never reached
that phase
that's a great point uh i became aware
of it
through my own experience because when
you first discover
when you whatever retire meaning you
leave the world full-time work is there
a lot of things that you don't expect
that you lose
you lose kind of how your time is
structured because when you're working
full-time that's done for you
to great to write
and all of a sudden you've got this
great
asset called freedom but you've got to
really downstroke your then right it's
like a thing you lose status
because you haven't had a title you
regarded someone now just
read a person that hits a lot of people
very very hard
and then again the purpose part of it
what's what's your purpose what's really
literally driving me
so the other reason why i thought it
would have impact was because so many
people are
demographically we are moving into this
phase of life
and it's totally different now because
people are living longer so a lot of
what we have around retirement is
designed for the old days where
retirement has lasted about eight years
on average let's go less like 30. wow
and so
what i'm really helping people do is
reimagine
this block of time
letting go of some of the preconceived
notions of what retirement it's it's not
necessarily since it's not a time of the
decline it's a time of expiration and
opportunity if you've got that
inclination to what put the point
right well do we from from what we're
seeing around the world you were seeing
the retirement phase um
prolonged much longer but do we also see
then
that the entrance to retirement is is
also adapting so are people entering
retirement much later and is that
compensated for in some way
there's a lot of things that are going
on currently there
one thing that's been consistent is the
age of retirement has been pretty pretty
consistent for a number of years
and the only other thing that's very
consistent is that about close to half
six 47 off hand
but people retire earlier than they play
on average about five minutes oh wow
because well
things be under control often
organizational restructurings downsides
etc can force people into retirement and
the family circumstances
are another factor in their own health
conditions may change so in some cases a
lot of cases people need to be ready for
this in advance because what would you
do if
this if you need to move into this
different space
the other thing that's going on now
currently is
site of the times is unretired
now it's not droves of people but it's
on the upswing it's been going on for
quite some time uh about this study by
the ram corporation and nicole mason
this at harvard which looked at
about
20 to 25 percent of people on retire
within the first five years
it's
you know prior to this card period
wasn't driven necessarily by the
financial need it was driven by some of
the
non-financial factors camaraderie
purpose collegiality et cetera and
people really wanted to have that
meetings now a lot of it's being driven
by people deciding hey i need to get
back to it things have changed
and people are working are coming back
so it's on the upswing about three
and a half percent i think last summer
thought a lot of people are on
retirement interest and that's what
actually would change the retirement
numbers during cover there's a couple
spaces with like different federal
reserve banks that showed that it wasn't
the people who retired more people
retire fewer people on retirement
interesting
so for people that are you know
approaching the end of their full-time
journey
what are maybe a few tangible things to
keep in mind or or to actively do that
you've found very helpful in in your
coaching you know that that any any
person that's reaching that phase will
benefit from even if they they don't get
to work with you one-on-one
sure couple of things one really pay
attention to your network and your
connections
before you leave now people struggle
with this because most jobs are
demanding people are very busy
both professionally personally and
sometimes the networking aspects of
things fall to the wasteland it's really
important because you also lose a lot of
social connectivity when you need
workplaces so cultivate those
connections particularly outside of your
company outside your professional sphere
because you want to really have
basically what i call a new tribe that
you may want to to build over time
second thing
is
start to invest a little bit more time
and so much on outside interests what
are the things that you love to do
if we'll leave at the time because you
will soon
or what did you used to do back in the
day did you yeah put aside
some people returned to those things but
that's a really great opportunity uh to
recultivate some of those some of those
those those interests
and number three really to start to to
when what future you could look like
what
fast forward out out a few years like
what could i be doing what are those
alternatives with all those options and
have some fun being creative with them
and then talk to people who are retired
moving a similar story to yours
what did they learn what would they do
over
what do they
know now that they were thinking it's
the year phenomenal joe thank you so
much for this conversation i hear so
much intentionality and
and passion and i'm
particularly inspired by this notion of
lifelong learning and the curiosity that
you embody and which is uh for for
myself a young learner that's a it's
probably the most important piece of it
all so joe thank you very very much
continue making a hugely positive impact
on people's lives and stay safe and stay
healthy
thanks michael great to meet you thank
you very very much
[Music]
you